نتنياهو في مواجهه الجميع هذا ما يمكن ان
نقوله على ما يحدث في اسرائيل 12 اسبوعا
مرت منذ بدايه الاحتجاجات في الشارع كانت
تزيد شدتها بين الحين والاخر لكن لا شيء
مثل الامس واليوم رئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو وجد ان الضغوط عليه ليست كافيه
فزادها بنفسه على نفسه باقاله وزير الدفاع
لتنتفض الشوارع الاسرائيليه ضده الضغط كان
كبيرا لذلك خرج نتنياهو في كلمه
للاسرائيليين قبل قليل ردح للمطالب واعلن
ارجاء التعديلات القضائيه مع مناقشتها في
الدوره القادمه من الكنيست لكن مع مرور
الاسابيع تغيرت المطالب في الشارع من
المطالبه بوقف مشروع الاصلاح القضائي الى
المطالبه برحيل نتنياهو نفسه
[موسيقى]
سنعطي فرصه لتمرير التعديلات القضائيه عبر
اجماع واسع لذا قررت تاجيل التعديلات
القضائيه لهذه الدوره من الكنيست حتى نصل
لاجماع لدينا اغلبيه في الكنيست تجعلنا
نناقش التعديلات القضائيه وستتم مناقشه
التعديلات القضائيه في الدوره القادمه من
الكنيست اود الاشاره الى اني حصلت على
موافقه اغلبيه زملائي في الحكومه لمنع
الحرب الاهليه عبر الحوار هذه الازمه
تجبرنا على التصرف بمسؤوليه
[موسيقى]
بنيامين نتنياهو من مواليد تل ابيب عام
سياسي اسرائيلي يراس حزب الليكود تولى
رئاسه الحزب عام
1993 تولى رئاسه الوزراء بين عامي
1996 وحتى
1999 واصبح اصغر رئيس وزراء في تاريخ
اسرائيل تولى المنصب مره اخرى من 2009 الى
2021 يعتبر صاحب اطول مده كرئيس حكومه في
تاريخ اسرائيل اصبح مجددا رئيسا للوزراء
في التاسع والعشرين من ديسمبر من عام 2022